[Música]
o filme cheio de mulheres lindas
eu sou o capitão jack sparrow muito bem
é claro agora somente infelizmente muito
melhor agora
boa noite a todos
bom é como vocês podem ver a pirataria
faz parte da minha vida
já há um bom tempo é o seguinte eu desde
pequeno muito pequeno muito jovem com os
meus cinco anos seis anos
eu sempre amei sempre foi apaixonado
pelo oceano o mar em si sempre me atraiu
muito
é muito engraçado se chega a ser um
pouco engraçado porque em muitos
momentos na beira mar brincando com
amigos amiguinhos é fazendo castelinho
brincando com baldinho carrinho
engraçado que eu lembro que eu sempre de
alguma forma estava olhando para o
horizonte estava na beira mar brincando
com eles não deixando de brincar claro
mas existia uma atração pelo mar pelo
movimento das ondas pelo compor do todo
e em determinados momentos eu chegava o
ponto de ter uma boa noção de que eu me
perdia eu encontrava naquele ambiente
mesmo sendo muito jovem muito novo e
naquela área naquele ambiente marítimo
como sempre me atraiu muito sempre
gostei muito de a praia mas vamos à
praia final de semana
mesmo chovendo assim eu sempre queria ir
à praia sem fio sempre está no mar a
cena tem essa ligação sempre e e tendo
essa ligação com o mar fazendo desenhos
na areia
eu depois que entrei no colégio eu eu
passei a notar que eu tinha uma certa
facilidade e fazer alguns desenhos
alguns rabiscos que anos depois se
tornaram desenhos já começaram a esses
rabiscos começaram a melhorar um
pouquinho e partindo desses desenhos que
eu comecei a fazer é a réplica que anos
depois claro que eu vi sabe aquela
réplicas de carrinhos que eu não podia
ter na época que os meus pais não
poderiam estar me dando porque naquela
época era muito caro e tal é difícil o
acesso então eu comecei a colocar em
prática
aqueles traços aqueles desenhos eu
comecei a fazer réplicas desses
carrinhos e tal anos depois já no
colégio sendo um amante da arte da mais
night a matemática não muito geografia
no bonito mas voltado para a educação
física mesmo amava porque ainda de vez
em quando não tinha aula é muito bacana
e aproveitaram para desenhar e colocar
em prática e procurar a aperfeiçoar
sempre então é tendo isso comigo desde
pequeno eu comecei a fazer algumas
réplicas desses carrinhos mas o meu
tempo era mais voltada à praia mas vou
tomar então eu comecei a fazer réplicas
de embarcações de navios do século 12
século 13 século 15 e com maior número
de detalhes possíveis é com canhões
amarra-se timão é aquela coisa nada toda
que forma a embarcação
pois bem é pra mim a sorte eu sendo o
amante de história do colégio é o acho
que a única matéria que gostar
muito depois das redes era a história
então amando muita história
eu e fazendo essas réplicas de
embarcações e tal
o tema sempre voltado ao mar e então eu
comecei a fazer essas réplicas e surgiu
então o filme piratas do caribe e quando
eu vi o navio a primeira cena do filme
na maldição do pérola negra etapa quando
viu na visão e preenchendo toda aquela
tela no cinema aí eu enlouqueci
e além claro que no filme mostrando
todas as riquezas de detalhes dos navios
e pistolas que eram usadas a vestimenta
e tal e e durante isso quando eu já
vinha colocando site em prática fazendo
réplicas e tal eu comecei a fazer
réplicas de produtos que são
considerados do tema do filme piratas do
caribe o meu primeiro a minha primeira
réplica foi da bússola uma bússola se
desde já que é usado no filme realmente
de madeira funciona é funcional sabe e
entende então para mim foi muito bacana
assim de ter realizado essa peça e ter
tido comigo e depois da bússola veio a
espada ea pistola na velha bota chapéu e
por aí foi
acabei montando todo trás e até então
não tinha uma certa indefinição no pará
onde eu iria levar esse trabalho que
também surgiu a idéia de começar a fazer
visitas e hospitais de levar a imagem do
maluco do do dia que espero para as
crianças principalmente é um público que
ama muito o personagem é muito cativante
e simpático além de atrapalhado de
maluco como ele é no filme é então eu
comecei a levar é esse personagem para
lugares onde precisava de algum tipo de
apoio tanto psicológico quanto emocional
então é esse tema é voltado mais a a um
lado emocional principalmente das
crianças e tal sempre me atraiu muito
sempre tive muita vontade de procurar
modificar isso de alguma forma
então acabei visitando alguns lugares
tal aí comecei a ser contratado para
festas de aniversário de casamento e tal
isso é muito bacana muito gratificante
pra mim que sou um amante do tema você
poderá levar a imagem do personagem e
graças a deus fazem oito anos que já
trabalha nesse nesse meio
já frequentei várias fotos eventos e tal
então isso é muito gratificante você
levar para um ambiente naquele tema que
você investiu e que você realmente tomou
por conta que você queria como profissão
não apenas como hobby tal algo
passageiro
a minha intenção era de realmente levar
o amor às pessoas ou seja que transmitiu
que o dia espero transmitir no filme ele
além de pirata tipo não é um pirata ou
12 todos aqui sabe ele além daquela
daquele lado atrapalhado maluco dele ele
está sempre agradando os próprios
piratas nos os aliados estão muito
engraçado e voltado isso e como eu me
identifico muito gosto muito do
personagem
sempre fui uma pessoa muito feliz muito
alegre desde de criança mesmo com
dificuldade problemas em procurei está
sorrindo sempre
e nesse meio de trabalhos e tal então um
dos trabalhos assim que me marcou muito
e eu vou lembrar sempre fui de uma de
uma festa de aniversário que eu
participe em santa rosa de lima
lá obteve um evento bacana muitas
pessoas e tal e em uma delas era um
cadeirante o menino joão pedro e o que
me chama muito atenção àquele menino é
que assim mesmo com toda a dificuldade
de locomoção e toda a dificuldade que
ele tinha naquele momento para ele andar
e tinha que ter ajuda da mãe dele então
eu cheguei até elite bateu fotos rio
muito conversou eu brinquei com ele
falei com todos ali mas a a minha
intenção maior era sempre está agradando
principalmente ele é uma pessoa especial
e uma pessoa que eu vi que também curtia
muito piratas do caribe
e aí num determinado momento da festa
estava jantando distante da onde ele
estava
e olhe que eu estava conversando até com
um amigo sintam na hora da janta e ver
aquela mão assim bateu nas minhas costas
de um livro atrás de si e em pé atrás de
mim ele toda aquela dificuldade de
locomoção
aí eu disse meu deus eu vou desmaiar
tipo assim é pra mim atuar mas eu acho
que não vou conseguir
então naquele momento ali eu fiquei
muito emocionado assim eu vi que a mãe
dele também também emocionada
mas ali naquele momento o expert ou
tomou conta e o roni ficou de fora então
eu acabei não me emocionando junto com
ela e ela diz o seguinte roni é incrível
porque se eu fazia muito tempo que ele
não se empolgava para andar o que ele
andou agora sabe então assim pra mim
esse tipo de frase que eu receber
demonstrou pra mim significou muito
porque ali eu tive uma prova maior ainda
de que o amor que eu tenho pelo meu
trabalho e esse amor que eu procuro
transmitir às pessoas de que quando você
ama o que você faz
com certeza os resultados serão
cinematográficos
eu considero isso muito pra mim é
indiferente da profissão de vocês aqui
quando vocês fizerem com muito amor e
carinho vai acontecer
sabe de repente o resultado pode demorar
um pouquinho mas vê esse resultado vai
aparecer vai acontecer e também é feito
de forma natural e então essa é uma fase
bem marcante que essa imagem dele pra
mim assistir com uma imagem muito magnet
é muito incrível e vale muito a pena
passa muito calor que rompeu um
pouquinho quente aí teve uma outra festa
que eu fui lá próximo da fúria tipo
fevereiro/2011 tipo um final de semana
bem tranquilo 44 graus aqui em criciúma
não era muito quente e aquele dia
propício pra e tal e da família tinha
entrado em contato
amigo três meses antes da festa faltando
dois dias para festas eles me ligaram
dizendo que não poderiam participar
eu não poderia participar da festa por
que não poderiam pagar o cachê do jack
tal aquela coisa
infelizmente a gente depende do dinheiro
se eu pudesse fazer meu trabalho de
graça faria não cobraria mas
infelizmente a gente tem que cobrar
ainda mais um pirata nem comigo não
preocupa o técnico tem que colocar em
prática estão bem e então eu sei que no
dia da festa que eu não deveria ter ido
tal é eu perguntei para a avó da menina
é a festa seria no mesmo local no mesmo
horário com o mesmo tema e tal questão
vai ser tudo igual mas infelizmente a
gente não vai poder trazer para a festa
aí o que o fez chegou neste sábado da
festinha dela amy a fazer um aninho e 44
graus lá fora e eu louco em uma praia
eu queria ir à praia mas deveria pensar
poxa à praia ela está há 24 horas por
dia todo o dia a menina ea fazer um
aninho de idade naquele sábado no outro
sábado já teria um aninho e eu não
queria participar daquele momento
fantástico da vidinha dela e dos
familiares
então o que eu fiz e me caracterizei fui
até o local da festa e foi maravilhoso
eu chorei a volta chorou a mãe dela
chorou então assim eles agradeceram
muito por ter ido à festinha
então assim é quando a avó dela me viu
né aquela nossa gente ele veio o tal que
ela tava carnê no colo de um aninho com
vestidinho piratas em a coisa mais linda
então ele aquele momento nenhum eu me
segurei assim mas já foi bem complicado
também
então é uma imagem foi um momento que
ficou marcado para mim tendo aí
ou seja mais uma vez eu provei pra mim
mesmo que o meu amor pelo meu trabalho
foi maior do que a vontade de ter ido
pra ela e realmente o que eu faço eu
faço com muito amor e carinho saúde
e aí o que acontece uma outra situação
que eu passei foi aqui no hospital são
josé
no setor de oncologia uma das pacientes
que tinha na época era uma tal de
rafinha
eu lembro muito dela e ela com cabelos
encaracolados olhinho claro e ela tava o
setor lana de oncologia minha batida
porque ela tinha certo aqui no edital
que ela estava deitada na cama assim com
aquela expressão bem abatida e quando eu
entrei no quarto e vê muito ela disse
que eu poderia entrar então quando eu
entrei no quarto e ouvir a expressão
dela mudar completamente a menina sentou
ela estava deitada ela sentou bem rápido
de ser o jack veio e tal
então foi maravilhoso e rio tinto juntos
a gente desenhou sabe foi incrível ela
me deu um bairro eu ganhei um bairro no
desenho
ela colocou no meu nome tal a esse
bairro é para o meu amado jack
meu deus que prêmio que paga esse tipo
de coisa sabe não existe valor no mundo
que supere esse tipo de coisa o abraço
de uma criança pra mim é sensacional não
têm e os com graça de deus se fosse eu
tenho o prazer de sentir na pele o que
johnny depp sente quando ele abraça as
crianças onde ele vai
os locais que revisita também então isso
é sensacional você tem que sentir na
pele mesmo para você entender ao certo
assim que eu estou falando em um outro
momento também que foi assim sensacional
também na minha vida incrível que vai
ficar marcado pra sempre nessas minhas
andanças como o dia esperando assim
nesse tipo de trabalho
quando meu filho era muito pequenininho
lá com os dois aninhos dele bem novinho
e ele me chamando de papai jack aí a
primeira vez que eu parecer que aparece
caracterizado na frente dele pensei
nossa meu filho vai ter um treco vai
cair duro na hora que ele vê o pai cheio
de cabelo aquela coisa lá de chapéu e
ele não muito pelo contrário ele ficou
parado sendo ele ficou me olhando sorrio
dele papa e jack lew disse o quê
disse livre sabe eu imaginava uma reação
de chorar e sair correndo dali mesmo que
normalmente em festinhas que já foi de
aniversário teve criancinhas que ficavam
assim né
tipo eu não sabia estava tendo um ataque
você era de felicidade ou de pânico mas
algumas novinhos têm pânico da imagem
isso aqui não é muito chegada é muito
cômico mas faz parte do trabalho e outra
fase muito forte que eu passei foi
quando a gente viajar no tratamento
longo como o vôo meu amado e até no vôo
ele tinha câncer e até então eu não
sabia que tinha a doença ele se
imaginava que estava doente e claro que
nós familiares não encontramos nada ele
levamos toda ajuda a ele à frente e eu
lembro que eu me despedir dele em
tubarão ele morava em tubarão eu fui
viajar para porto alegre em porto alegre
no caso voltando dez minutos para entrar
no evento na festa eu fiquei sabendo
pelo meu celular que ele tinha falecido
aí o pai da menina perguntou tipo oneto
quer desistir
isto quiser desistir da festa não tem
problema nenhum porque só nós sabemos o
que nos traz aqui vai ser surpresa para
os convidados e tal disse pra ele não se
eu tô aqui essa festa vou dedicar
completamente à ele sabe então foi uma
festa maravilhosa e muitos abraços e
isso pra mim não tem preço que pague
então assim é uma frase que eu deixo
para vocês é o seguinte faça tudo que
você tiver de fazer coloque sempre o
amor em primeiro lugar sabe qualquer
tipo de profissão que você tenha coloque
o amor em primeiro lugar que os
resultados serão cinematográficos
acredita em mim e esse sou eu o ronnie
peterson
fui lá